i
took a certain perverse pleasure um that
the guy
who was like the lead voice in rat
tattooey
um
comes in to voice the deep's mangina
you know like the guy from secret life
of pets too like a real
real evergreen superstar when it comes
to
animated voices and for him to be like
this kind of
animated male vagina on this guy's chest
i just was really
hilarious to me man it just really made
me laugh
um it really felt like we were trying to
actively ruin
his career as a as a voiceover artist i
was such a fan of that show i liked the
comic book
okay uh but what they did
with those characters and with that
world and
um with the character of homelander who
you did not you know
you think well it's going to be um
it's going to be the boys it's going to
be you know those characters
and then but you get just as invested in
these evil
damage superheroes that i tweeted about
it and quote about it he said uh you
know i'd love to play a part
one way or another if if it ever comes
up and uh that's always a mistake to say
to me because
because i'll always say well it's funny
you should that
the creator just contacted me and said
do you want to do this thing on the show
i'm like absolutely
and that's how it happened god bless him
he was
he was willing to do it and and was more
excited
when he i i said well you'll actually be
playing the deep skills
a lot of actors would say uh i'm
actually
busy that year i can't do it but but
he was like oh my god that's the best i
can i'm so
in and he's a really really good dude